(upbeat orchestral music)
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
- Thank you everyone.
I mean, it's just wonderful
to see this room and see all of you here.
And so many of you have been
part of the Institute's work,
but I, I actually wanna start
by thanking Ryan Coogler
and Chloe Zhao.
It was such, yes.
(audience applauds)
It has been such a
privilege to support both
of you on your
unforgettable first features
means the world to me.
So thank you for being here
with your full heart for us.
For over four decades, the Sundance Labs,
the Festival, have
provided unwavering support
for a next generation of artists.
And at the same time, we've worked
with many others in this
room, so many in this room
to build an industry
and an audience for
groundbreaking independent film.
(audience applauds)
I just wanna say you are
all change makers here.
So I'm gonna talk about
my path to Sundance,
which began in Boston.
And now I'm gonna take you back to 1981
and very unexpectedly, a
close friend, Lynn Benjamin,
asked me a question that
would change my life.
Would I consider coming to Sundance, Utah
for the first month long filmmaker's Lab
that Robert Redford was starting up?
Lynn also introduced me to my husband,
but that's another story here.
I arrived at Sundance on
a beautiful blue sky day.
I still remember the whispering
music of the quaking Aspens
and the sight of Majestic
Mount Timpanogos.
In that magical setting,
Redford laid out his radical vision,
well-established screenwriters, directors,
actors would mentor bold
independent filmmakers
early in their careers.
Redford wanted to build a community
that honored creative
freedom, risk-taking,
a culture of generosity,
which meant the world to me,
and storytellers from
underrepresented communities.
For me, this was love at first sight.
My journey might have ended at
that first visit to Sundance,
but I wanted more and I asked
for five minutes with Bob
before leaving the mountain,
and I got those five minutes.
So with all the confidence
that I could muster,
I told him he needed
me to open an LA office
and help him fulfill the
vision that he had created.
He looked at me for a moment
and then he said, "Yeah, sure,
call me when you get there."
(laughter)
And right then and
there, I learned quickly
that when somebody says,
"yes," stop talking.
(laughter)
(audience applauds)
I returned to Boston
and thought that maybe I had
imagined the conversation.
Nervously, I called his
assistant the next day,
told her what Bob had said.
She laughed and said she would check
with him and let me know.
The next day I got the call
that forever changed my life.
So today, with immense
gratitude, I'm honored
to accept the Jean
Hersholt Humanitarian Award
in recognition of my
lifelong work supporting
independent visionary filmmakers,
as a founding director of
the Sundance Institute.
(audience cheers and applauds)
I wanna congratulate the
extraordinary artists
who are also being honored here tonight.
I mean, what an amazing group.
Angela Bassett, Mel
Brooks, Carol Littleton.
So moved by all of you.
And my huge thanks to
Janet Yang, Bill Kramer
of the Academy, Marina Zenovich,
for making such a moving short
and for all the governors
for this incredible honor.
The journey that brought me to this moment
was not taken alone,
and it was shared every
step and every mile
with my brilliant colleagues
over four decades.
I wanna acknowledge
Joana Vicente, our CEO,
Ebs Burnough, chair of our board.
llyse McKimmie, the deputy director
of our feature film program,
Tammy Rosen, our head
of communications, along
with our extraordinary board
members, funders, partners,
actors, crews, everyone who's been part
of the credible community that
was built and the journey.
I also wanna extend my deepest gratitude
to the filmmakers I've had
the privilege of working with.
And I really underline it is
a privilege whose storytelling
has ignited profound change
through their creative
brilliance and courage
to spark vital conversations.
Their stories have become a
powerful force for empathy,
understanding, advocacy,
and yes, entertainment.
(audience applauds)
And over the past three years,
the filmmakers who've been
celebrated with Academy Awards
for Best Picture have
all been supported early
in their careers by the
Sundance Labs and Festival.
(audience cheers and applauds)
I'm just gonna name them, Daniel Kwan
and Daniel Scheinert,
(audience applauds)
Sian Heder,
(audience cheers and applauds)
and Chloe Zhao.
The Labs wouldn't exist without
the artists who participate
as creative advisors.
There are many in this room tonight,
including Angela Bassett.
We loved having you at the Lab.
(audience applauds)
Their generosity and wisdom shared
with the next generation
has forever helped
to shape the visionary work
and lives of thousands of filmmakers
from all over the world.
I'm also most deeply grateful
for the inspiration provided by my family.
I grew up in a house
surrounded by my father's art
and was immersed in a world
where creativity knew no bounds.
Warren Satter's work was everywhere,
serving as a constant reminder
of how art can bring beauty
and truth into the world.
Equally impactful was the
influence of my mother,
Helen Satter, a resilient
holocaust survivor
who recently celebrated
her hundredth birthday.
(audience applauds)
Her unwavering spirit, determination
and compassionate heart taught me
that true fulfillment comes
from using our privileges
and talents to make a positive difference
in the lives of others.
My incredible husband, David Latt,
(audience applauds)
has been a constant source of inspiration,
compassion, and love.
As a writer and producer,
he helped me understand
what artists need to fulfill
their creative lives.
And David has always been there for me
sharing our mutual love
of family and giving back.
We've experienced profound inspiration
and joy with our son, Franklin Latt.
(audience applauds)
He's carried on the legacy
of supporting artists
and creatives as his
ongoing work and purpose.
Through his role as co-head of
Motion Picture Talent at CAA,
he has worked hard to ensure
that artists can thrive in our industry
and find the opportunities
to do great work.
I know that many of you are aware
that we lost our younger
son, Michael Latt,
just a month ago,
to a tragic act of violence.
Michael devoted his career
to supporting artists,
championing organizations
that led elevated
artists of color,
creating inclusive communities,
and leveraging storytelling
for enduring social change.
Tonight I share this honor with Michael.
(audience applauds)
He will be forever remembered,
living in our hearts
as someone who led with love,
always showing up with hope,
compassion, and kindness.
Nine years ago, the icon Harry Belafonte,
who is also celebrated with this honor,
shared these beautiful words
which have such meaning for me.
Each and every one of you
has the power, the will,
the capacity to make a difference
in the world in which we live.
Artists are the gatekeepers of truth.
We are civilizations' anchor,
we're the compass for
humanity's conscience.
Art in its highest form is art that serves
and instructs society
and human development.
Let us take this moment
to celebrate the collective
impact we can have
when we come together as
an inclusive community.
And I'm really talking
about all of us here.
Let's stand side by side
to support the artists
who shape our world now
and into the future.
I hope you'll join me
in this essential work.
It is essential work,
and find your own special way to give back
and tell your stories.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
(theme music)